good morning Hank it's Tuesday so on the
YouTube channel healthcare triage doctor
Aaron Carroll often says that data is
not the plural of anecdote but in a
world where there are so many factual
anecdotes out there it can be difficult
to see the larger truths that data can
tell us for instance there are terrible
crimes every day in the United States
but that doesn't change the fact that
the u.s. homicide rate is lower than it
was 10 or 20 or 30 or 40 or 50 years ago
anyway to try to understand the world
better I often use Maps and here are
seven that I found especially helpful
first we have this map which divides the
human population into tenths I like this
one because it reminds me that Canada
the United States Mexico most of the
Caribbean Chile Peru and more only
constitute 1/10 of the world's
population the world is so much bigger
than my world and the human story is so
much bigger than the human stories I
usually hear also since I mentioned Peru
Peru is big as is Somalia those are not
among the seven maps by the way those
are bonus maps you're welcome then
there's this map from our world and data
which shows the average years of school
people had around the world in 1950 the
yellow is between 0 & 2 years the green
between 2 & 6 and then as the colors get
darker people get better educated here's
1970 and then here's 1990 and here's
what it looked like in 2010 there are
still huge gaps between rich and poor
countries and between rich and poor
people within many countries but even so
all around the world kids are getting
more educational opportunities which is
good because it means more potential
innovators to solve all of the problems
we are leaving those kids with speaking
of which here's what global co2
emissions look like in 1950 almost all
the emissions coming from the world's
wealthiest countries
here's 1970 and here's 1990 and this is
2016 a few countries starting to get
lighter but only a few meanwhile this
map shows average temperature changes
between 1965 and 2014 red areas are
where the earth has gotten warmer white
areas or where the temperature hasn't
changed in blue areas are where it's
gotten cold there is no blue then
there's this amazing map of global
borders and when they were created I'll
put links in the doobly-doo so you can
explore all these maps in detail but the
fascinating thing to me here is just how
recent many national borders are like we
often think of nation states as
intractable realities and national
orders as fixed but in fact most
national borders are less than 120 years
old
okay let's return to our world and data
to look at this map of the percentage of
births in 1991 that were attended by
trained health care workers doctors
nurses midwives etc in Brazil it was
under 70% in India 34 percent in Mali 26
percent now let's flash forward to 2015
in Mali 60 percent of births are
attended by a health care worker in
India it's over 80 percent and in Brazil
it's over 95 percent the benefits of
this are staggering 500 22,000 mothers
died in childbirth in 1991 in 2015 300
3,000 did we still have a long way to go
but that is real progress and lastly
let's look at my favorite map life
expectancy I know this is a
controversial position but I believe
that human lives should be long and
healthy here's what global life
expectancy looked like in 1980 and
here's what it looked like 35 years
later all around the world low and
middle income countries from China to
India to Peru to Angola have seen life
expectancy go up by at least 10 years
and in some cases 20 so thank you Matt
makers for giving me hope and also
inappropriate fear Hank before I go one
thing I enjoy sponsoring AFC Wimbledon
so much and it has made me want to
sponsor other things so if you're part
of a club or team or organization or
whatever that could use modest
sponsorship like think high three digits
too low four digits email me at sparks
fly up at gmail.com with the subject
line sponsorship and when I say
sponsorship I don't mean donation which
is a separate thing I mean getting some
kind of marketing value in exchange for
the sponsorship like our logo on your
uniform or something if it sounds like I
said that to make sure I'm cool with the
IRS I did but right sparks fly up at
gmail.com I apologize in advance for all
the awesome things I won't be able to
sponsor but I'm gonna try to sponsor at
least a few things Hank I'll see you on
Friday